[Musique]
au sénat les groupes politiques doivent
comprendre au moins 10 membres contre 15
à l'assemblée nationale au palais du
luxembourg jusqu'en juin il y avait six
gros les communistes les socialistes les
écologistes
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen qui comprend aussi
bien des élus de gauche que de droite
les centristes le groupe l'est
républicain et enfin si sénateur
n'appartenant à aucun groupe
mais l'élection d' emmanuel macron a
tout bousculé avec l'irruption d'un
groupe de la république en marche et les
groupes ont tous au moins une fois la
parole à chaque séance de questions
d'actualité
les sénateurs n'ont inscrit posent eux
une question seulement toutes les quatre
séances enfin seuls les groupes et leur
président intervienne pour décider de
l'ordre du jour peuvent demander la
constitution d'une commission denquête
ou un vote par scrutin public c'est à
dire avec des bulletins secrets à la
tribune
[Musique]
à